[Music]
welcome back to an exciting episode of
the careful boys
and yes there's a geo here there's a geo
we have a a lady with a massive clip
that fits in with us
oh how do you know about my clip bro
welcome to the show bro
and today we got brandon lee in the
house
[Applause]
just to clarify he's not the lady with
the massive clip that joe's talking
about
he's actually really cool
so brandon welcome to the show man how
you doing i think you're doing good good
man good brandon is a undefeated
professional boxer right 24 so i heard
and you know why because every time i
look at instagram some uh fighters will
pop up because i'm into you know the the
male sports and then um
when i saw him i was like yes
because every time i see an asian
[ __ ]
push it down i'm like yes i'm too
[ __ ] scared to do that [ __ ] but
[ __ ] i've lived vicariously through
you man [ __ ] it up that's the perfect
turn to me like yeah when you see asian
dudes that are like into cosplay and
stuff do you go
[Laughter]
like
i feel like everyone's like everyone has
their own thing i'm in the cosplay hey
good answer no you're just nice
are you into cosplay at all would you
ever consider that i mean that's not
that's not my thing but i mean if you
like that go ahead because i see asian
dudes at comic con i'm like why man what
and then i'm like hi bart be more like
him dude
dude do that kind of thing my crew does
cosplay i don't know
he goes through there because he's
booked to [ __ ] speak at comic con and
he's judging everybody there why is
that's here he's just shaking his head
the whole time like these [ __ ] people
he's asian
he's asian back to the boxing let's uh
back to the boxing i do want to say
though
that
this is for asian person this is like
the equivalent of making it on joe rogan
it was a big deal yeah that's just
pretty big
welcome
welcome to the asian rogan show
he's like [ __ ] who booked me on this
[ __ ] you know what's funny though is
like the first the first thing anthony
asks brandon's like hey you ever seen
one of these episodes goes nope and i
was like i love this dude already
there's people be like yeah man it's
[ __ ] dope and i'm like get your
hollywood ass out of here you don't
[ __ ] know what we do here actually
like a year and a half ago maybe two
years i was at um
i think i was like a blaze piece of
biology
and this kid came up to me
i went to i went to school with him and
then i haven't seen him for a while and
he's like
i heard i heard you on a bar kwon's
broadcast i was like what
and he's like yeah they were talking
about you what and he was like i was
like what and then um he's back talking
[ __ ] yeah that's in the back i'll beat
his [ __ ] ass
that's like he's here right now they're
talking about me and then or you guys i
was just [ __ ] around dude
don't take it seriously dude he always
talks about how he kicked your ass crazy
i don't know
i think he was asking like oh how do i
know you or some [ __ ] like that i was
like oh we just connected through ig
but yeah i thought it was pretty dope
yeah yeah i saw you like yeah i saw on
the explore page i'm like what the [ __ ]
this is crazy and that's how i think i
reached out instagram explorer dude i
bet you anything because you guys are
liking his videos that [ __ ] pops up on
mine probably oh cause that's where you
saw him on the explore page of instagram
i'm glad we're talking that's right
he hears about you through the explore
page every time you do pop up though i'm
like mad props like like like yup and i
get distracted to be honest there's like
a hot girl and then when they pop up i
get distracted and it's hard to compete
i follow them instead i'm sorry
you're competing against boobs man
it's kind of hard to do uh so when did
you when did you get into boxing like
that that's what geos y'all um thank you
i started training at the age of six but
i've been in the boxing gym since age
two and i had my first amateur fight at
age eight oh [ __ ] wait did you say two
i've been in the boxing gym since two
years what does that mean like you've
been observing or you've just been
[ __ ] around [ __ ] people
just observing [ __ ] around uh because
my older brother he's 90 years older
than me so i used to go to the gym with
him and um
he used to be like training and i just
watched and you know just trying to
mimic him playing right now
was he like your first inspiration to
get into boxing yeah by far yeah
probably how come you made it he didn't
then
[Music]
[Laughter]
so disappointed i think uh asian dad
questions that's what he was saying on
the podcast by the way
i think probably our stars are totally
different he had more like a punch of
style
and um
i think
in boxing oh you have to explain that to
everybody everything is punching right
because when i hear that i'm like that's
a punchy style more like yeah like more
like a coming forward mike tyson style
like oh
gotcha i feel like my style is like more
i could come forward or like a box you
could do both yeah finesse yeah it all
depends like on my opponent
and i just feel like uh
i'm so not a fighter so like when you
say i can come forward or i can box what
does box mean relationship the box is
like i can move around like i could be
like a mayweather got it i can move
around i can counter punch
like come forward apply pressure so all
depends on my opponent um and plus i
think i had like more opportunity and
more experience
in the because i said i had a close to
200 amateur fights damn
yeah
so so when did your brother stop going
then they like aged
he stopped like age 16 or something and
then he started again he stopped again
like a year later because he fought you
and he was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i suck no
i think i really think that uh it was
kind of like what you said earlier about
applying that with your son i think my
my dad was too hard on him at first i
burnt him out maybe huh so he burns him
out so i think when he's when he started
with me he kind of
it on a different path yeah every time
you win then does your dad look over to
your brother and just have a tear no
like would you regret it
i [ __ ] up on the first one or did you
tell your brother to hop over the ropes
we wanted this together
just crying
is your papa your coach yeah okay yeah
this is day one do you ever look at
other coaches and like yo pops that
guy's kind of better than you man
that's what he does that's what this guy
does we went to go see a coach one time
um i remember i made my television debut
back in 2019
and we had hella people reach out to us
and one of the coaches was buddy mcgirt
oh really yeah so he's like a big time
coach
and he reached out to us and we went to
go work with them for i think we went
like we one time
and uh
we worked with them and then we went
back home and me and my dad were talking
like
damn the same things that i did with him
you and i are doing it so what's the
point of switching it up so that's tight
yeah so can you walk us through like a
training day or something like that
when i'm in camp or not i can't when i'm
when i'm training in cabin okay let's do
ink oh wake up five o'clock go for a run
how long just two miles
uh come back make some breakfast make my
dad some breakfast he'll go to work
what's your breakfast like is it like
diet or is it like cereal like kimchi
and fun
off camp
oh i'll [ __ ] wake up make ramen or
in camp i'll probably eat like
three pieces of bacon a piece of bread
and one egg
um and i'll probably just chill go
grocery shopping clean the house
try to work off my breakfast and then
i'll probably go take a nap wake up uh
you take a nap right after you wake up
i like to sleep
okay he's a professional athlete bro
he's at the peak performance
he's got a he's got a champ dude that's
why you're messing up so when i wake up
from my nap i love how he has
he ran but he hasn't got to the workout
yet yeah he's just just like a chill
down no dude when he goes jogging he
beats up every other jogger
he leaves
i wake up from my nap i probably do like
so i also go to cal state san bernardino
so i'll probably last semester i didn't
go to school too wow
so what are you studying criminal
justice oh [ __ ] no way so i wake up
maybe i'll do a class or i might just
skip the class for the day
that's what i like to hear dude good for
you man i'll either
our last cap i went out to eat a lot for
lunch so i went to go get like a little
steak some potatoes some asparagus
and then for dessert if i have like
creme brulee
damn you fancy i like that that's like a
solid day details right now making you
feel like how do you crack the creme
brulee like i just thought you could
crack it
so so this is a better question like
what's your how different is your life
off camp versus in camp
a lot different yeah oh yeah so what's
in camp and off camp
um
what do you mean like for the people who
don't know and me too including one has
cereal one has bacon yeah yeah so one so
pretty good camp is like everything's
serious i don't go out no more because
are you training for a fight or like
yeah you got to make weight or whatever
i'm training for a fight i got to make
weight my mentality is totally different
i'm watching more film
um i'm not going out when i'm out of
camp i'm going to irvine once a week to
go eat i'm doing podcasts yeah i'm
waking up whenever but do you still
train like like like right
yeah right now i'm still training five
days a week but it's not as not any
clothes as heavy as i'm in camp
so after my class
uh i'll get lunch
and then after that i'll chill my dad
come home we'll work out
and then after that i go run three miles
or
four miles so you're going to twice
a day why he needs those extra naps bro
and that's just not even part of the
training it's just that's just you just
have to run those two times it's not
even part of the the myth and just to
get the cardio yeah and then so i'd be
like a monday or that'd be like a monday
and or that'd be like that'll be like a
tuesday and thursday a monday is kind of
similar but i go sparring so what do you
do for fun what do you do to unwind
after outside beat people up that's
that's one side of it but what's the
other what's the other side yeah like
your vice yeah yeah something i like to
do is cook but i can't really cook one
on the cup why not because i'm i gotta
watch one of these
but like off camp though you enjoy
cooking oh that's cool what's your
favorite dish i'll see like chicken
wings or something i'm like damn that
sounds good so i'll make that i can make
like shrimp tacos chicken parmesan
wings whatever i know
today's video is brought to you by
bon bon's mission it's simple make the
most comfortable clothes ever and match
every item sold with an equal item
donated so when you buy bone bust you're
also giving to someone in need boom buzz
designed their socks shirts and
underwear to be so comfortable that you
can't wait to put it on every day
everything they make is soft seamless
tagless and has a luxuriously cozy feel
they're made from super soft materials
like merino wool
pima cotton and even cashmere which
makes them perfect for those cozy winter
layers there's a pair of bomba socks for
everything you do they come in tons of
options like comfy performance styles
for every sport and activity that keeps
you moving bomba's t-shirts are designed
with thoughtful design features like
invisible seams and soft fabrics and the
perfect weight so they hang just right
bomba's underwear has a barely their
feel with second skin support that makes
you even forget that they're even there
whoa and did you know that socks
underwear and t-shirts are the most
requested things at a homeless shelter
that's why bone bust donates one item
for every one item that you buy so far
bonebox customers like you have donated
50 million essential items of clothing
so if you want some comfortable clothing
for a good cause make sure you go to
bumbus.com
off the record to get 20 percent off
your purchase that's bone bust
b-o-n-b-a-s dot com slash off the record
to get 20 percent off so you got a fight
coming up right potentially potentially
yeah march or april i should be back
going for that 25-0 right big 25 yeah
what what what do you feel like is a
i don't know i don't know what like the
tiers of goals are in terms of you know
for a fighter in your stature like
what's like a next milestone for you
he's trying to buy a tiger yeah that's
what all the boxers and then face tat
afterwards
you think about face tats
i do want to get a tab no i'm not in the
face though uh i think winning a world
title world title yeah because i'm very
uh
last year for 2021 i won prospect of the
year so i feel like the next step would
be
i mean maybe get contender of the year
or win a world title when you uh like
each time you're undefeated and you add
more and more does it feel
like there's this huge pressure of
losing ever you know i mean like because
it's almost like like let's say you get
to like 30 40 and you haven't had a
single loss like you always hear
fighters go oh man that like loss
took away is that is he being a [ __ ] he
says that i feel right now like if manny
pacquiao were to lose it's like who
cares yeah he lost so many times ready
no
if i were to lose right now it'd kind of
be like
oh he wasn't that good anyway it kind of
they're so disloyal boxing fans are
hella i mean there's been times not like
laker fans there have been times where
you go to a fight and they'll be let's
say you're from let's say you're from
this city they'll be cheering you on and
let's say you're getting beat up now
they're they'll start booing you
it's crazy or they're starting for the
other guy does that uh ignite your fire
more where you're like [ __ ] you then and
then you just
go balls i do have like a lot of a lot
of doubters out there so i while i'm
training is like of course i want to win
but the same time i have like something
to prove how obsessed are you about your
opponent when you're in camp do you like
think about them every i'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of this much i do think
about him every day but it's not like
i'm gonna beat him up it's more like
what can't what can i do that's better
than him you know so like i look at
every aspect of fashion to him i'm tired
of him i'm better looking at him hell
yeah
on everything wow it's interesting what
motivates different people because um we
did mma and our karate teacher did a
full contact karate competitions and he
told us that when he went up the way he
prepped
is he would walk up and imagine
that his opponent raped his sister
so he would walk up to him and say why
did you rape my sister and then [ __ ]
they're standing together and he's like
what
what like he would chant that like why
did you work with my sister why'd you
like he would say that and the circuit
that he fought in was like it's called
the tsubaki challenge it's like very
small right it's all bragging rights
like it's there's no trajectory for that
career
but for him it was like winning a
[ __ ] gold medal at the olympics maybe
that's like the you know i feel like as
men we all kind of have like ego maybe
that's part of it or something yeah but
it's an old school like mentality i'm
going into battle i'm gonna kill it's
like method acting right but fighting
he's a down day lewis karate daniel
i mean there's a lot of things that
motivate me a lot of things but i could
say that one of the things is like they
want to eat or don't want to starve so i
guess it kind of be like the same thing
we use survival yeah for him it's anger
everyone's motivated by different things
yeah
for you it's like after this i'ma get
chicken wings
right and then for him it's more like i
don't want to die
when you're in the zone what kind of
stuff like can derail you
wait are you working for the other side
you're gonna trap him you're gonna
you're gonna watch this [ __ ] [ __ ]
trap his ass watch out for bart dude if
you had a weakness that you could
exploit right now as a boxer
for example like for example um
when she used to be on the show
very regularly like you know we're we're
both castmates but we're also
significant others right so in the
morning we would have a like no [ __ ]
policy because we need to bring our a
game to whatever our sport that we play
right which is common i know [ __ ]
like no fighting like you keep it if
it's something that's dumb someone
forgot the like toilet seat or just
things that it used to you would nitpick
about it's like doesn't [ __ ] matter
let's get our asses here and we're gonna
have a good day that's all that matters
right any tiny little thing that we
would have usually bickered about
doesn't matter like for you is there
like a these are the x y and z things i
got to do to make sure i have a
like a good day or do you like if you
like stub your toe on the couch like
[ __ ] man [ __ ] my training
i feel like the day of the fight as long
as i have a good breakfast a decent
lunch i'm good to go um that's all that
matters like road rage someone else is
[ __ ] with built different does it
doesn't affect you that's why he's 25
it's funny because i had i had my buddy
drive up my car uh because he went to my
fight i had to drive with my car and i
texted him i was like if anything
happens you crash someone hits you don't
tell me it's after the fight
gotta stand up don't tell me until after
the fight bro
your next opponent's about hey you're
home you crashed your car
because it's so important to stay in the
zone yeah i mean i don't want no
distractions i don't want i don't want
to think about anything that
doesn't need to be thought over in the
moment how come you decided the pro
route instead of the olympic route so i
would have made the 2020 olympics and i
wanted to go to the olympics but the
thing was that when you turn 17
when you go uh to uh international
tournaments they take they took off the
headgear oh so i figured if [ __ ] if i'm
gonna get hit with all the headgear
might as well get paid for it um
and i'm glad i did turn pro cause you
know the olympics got delayed
yeah decision and that's true yeah yeah
because you don't get money off of that
brandon how many times do you want to
fight this year 2022 three times three
times yeah three times so when you when
the head cure comes up obviously more
risk right so you got to be like more
strategic and selective
with who you fight when you fight how
many how many times you fight exactly
well
uh
so in the amateur games the dudes i
fighting with no headgear you're finding
the best of the best everyone from i
mean
you find the best dudes so you got to
watch your elbows you got to watch your
head butts and let's say let's send me
bart fight he'll kick his ass for sure
let's say we fight
let's say we fight but he gave me a cut
i can't fight something for it i cannot
well i'm supposed to move up because i
won i can't fight tomorrow because now i
have a cut so now he goes what even
though you beat me
damn that's crazy i think at least i
think so yeah
it works like this just throwing elbows
everywhere dude how do matchups happen
uh for you nowadays like how does that
even happen in the system of that um i
have a manager so my manager handles all
that
are they looking for
uh a specific type of person they're
they're are they always trying to go up
a ladder or they're like are there like
training bouts because you know you're
trying to go up to another guy like how
is that systematically um it all depends
because so there's four main world
titles in the professional boxing game
wbc ibf
uh wba wbo so right now i'm number nine
by the ibf so that so that means that
potentially i can fight for ibf world
title
in the next couple fights you're a top
10 guy now exactly
so all depends which direction you want
to go um which one do you want first i
feel like any world title would be you
know a huge accomplishment
just because i mean as soon as you
become a world champion you make history
books so
i feel like so i'll be happy to have
anyone yeah
i got i got a question so so you you're
you're close to your dad right and he's
your coach
what if one day to take it to the next
level
you got to get another coach
and then
what do you think your dad would say
would you you think he'll be like no
[ __ ] that we're going to ride or die
together or would you do you think he'll
be like
nah you gotta do this of course my
father always wants the best for me but
i feel like like i said
i mean we're very experienced with other
coaches and if it's not broken why fix
it
um my father is getting older he's like
he's gonna be 55 this year he only
weighs like 140 pounds so obviously he
can't hold the mitts for me or he can't
hold like
the heavy punches for me so i have i
have an assistant coach and he does all
the heavy lifting pretty much i see but
it's his strategy
his like training his strategy um
i mean he'll be sitting down on the
chair and he'll be looking at everything
but at the same time it's good to have
my second coach because there's times
where there's stuff that my dad doesn't
see that he sees and your dad was a
boxer too
oh
what do you feel like uh is like your
dad's strengths as a coach specifically
him um just be my father he just knows
what to push knows knows what's i mean
uh
you know it sounds weird but like think
of me as a robot he knows what created
me so he knows what i'm capable of so
when i'm when i'm having a bad day or
something he knows i'm better than that
so he tells me
he tells me what we need to work on so i
could go have you ever trained before
and then going hard to look always
knocked out
he's like
[ __ ] i'm trying to show you
there's times where i'll be [ __ ] jump
roping like going hard he's like on his
phone like
see
[ __ ] all right hit that girl
he'll just get up and go smoke a
cigarette or something
you mentioned you mentioned that there
was another coach that entered the
picture that you guys were kind of like
dabbling about like considering working
with him who's this other coach uh buddy
mcgirt so he used to be a fighter as
well and uh he's he's worked with a lot
of big names what's the most notable
people that hit workplaces on top of my
head
recently uh sergey kovalev he fought
canelo
yeah he's a russian dude
snap but he's fine he's [ __ ] he's
worked with uh old timers oh okay just
for fun if you could fight anybody in
the world who would be
anybody probably logan paul oh
[ __ ] oh
go get
why not jake paul oh no uh jake paul
only because like people
a lot of people think that they're
actual boxers you know yeah
and um
just because you started boxing a year
ago doesn't make you a boxer yeah i mean
there's mice including myself we've been
doing this since the age of you know six
years old all our life that's all we
know yeah and for them to just hop in
the game and and be the main event i
don't think it's right for the other for
the boxing community do they kind of
like look down at that like who the [ __ ]
are these [ __ ] a lot of people
do
but at the same time a lot of people are
saying oh yeah it's good for the sport
but at the same time i'm like
i don't know it's like it brings new
eyes but at the same time it disrespects
all the hard work you guys put in in a
way yeah but um so my assistant coach he
took his son to uh
when logan paul fought ksi
and uh logan paul was the main event and
then devin haney was the co-main event
so devin he's a legit boxer he's a good
boxer yeah i think he's a he's a world
champion he has like a wbc
he has a wbc uh belt
i guess the the crowd there wasn't me
watching them any they were just on the
phone like [ __ ] vlogging or whatever
yeah and then of course when logan
fought then so they're not going to hear
supportive boxing they're just here
supporting uh you just want to see does
that increase the purse though like
because the sponsorship gets higher so
then therefore that's when it's kind of
good for the sport i really don't know i
did i did hear that logan paul or jake
paul threw an extra 50 at people's
purses on his last fight that's kind of
tight that's pretty cool that's kind of
tight do you think like the paul
brothers get into boxing is kind of like
dennis rodman playing basketball address
that's wrong is good though
never mind he was even better
that is bad but paul brothers you heard
it here brandon lee's coming for you
and if that's not cool we can edit that
out yeah yeah let us know man
[Music]
you